Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David,
here is a caller who is not happy with my
analysis about the Kanye West anti-Semitism
situation from yesterday. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hi. I was watching today's
episode from November 1st, and I
found it a little bit problematic
how confidently David speaks on the motive of
where, like Kanye is. Anti-Semitism is absolutely
abhorrent and unacceptable. No exceptions. Full
stop. Yes. But you really need a medical expertize
of of some kind to be able to assume that his
anti-Semitism isn't coming from the mental illness
because it's actually incredibly common with
bipolar type two and schizophrenia that they have
very conspiratorial beliefs. I have had friends
who have gotten sick and then gotten better and
believed very unhinged, conspiratorial things. We
should also keep in mind that Kanye has a lot of
distaste and a lot of distrust for black people
as well. And the Black Lives Matter movement.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, listen, let me address
this. What is the point that I was making
yesterday? Think back to Mel Gibson. Mel
Gibson got completely drunk and got pulled over
and he immediately said to the cop, Are you
a Jew? And he went on an anti-Semitic rant.
And then it was blamed on the alcohol. And one of
the things that was widely accepted at the time
was drinking didn't make Mel Gibson anti-Semitic.
It's not that you without being exposed to
anti-Semitic conspiracy theories, you drank and
suddenly you believe the Jews controlled banking,
right? The alcohol can't make you. It has to be
in there already. And so the point with Connie is,
yes, people become paranoid and conspiratorial
when they are suffering from a number of different
mental illnesses. But the things about which they
become conspiratorial aren't planted there. What
I'm saying is, if you lived outside of a society
in which anti-Semitic tropes and beliefs were
perpetuated, you could start suffering from
bipolar two, and your paranoia would be about
the police watching you or something that is
there already that you were aware of. You you're
not all of a sudden going to absent having that
information or those claims somewhere already.
You're not going to start believing those
particular things simply because you drink
too much or you start having a manic episode or
whatever the case may be. That's the point. So
what I. There is no doubt that were were were
Connie. Better mental health wise. He very
well might not be saying these things and might
not even think them to the degree that he does.
But these are beliefs that we know have been
floating around in Kanye's head for a long time.
That's the point that I was trying to make
on the bonus show today. We will talk about
Jair Bolsonaro, signaling he will
cooperate with the transfer of power,
but not conceding defeat. We're going to
talk about a total lockdown at Shanghai,
Disneyland in China, wild situation.
And we will talk about a Democratic
candidate who was beaten and knocked, knocked
unconscious in his home. That's Richard Reiner.
This is crazy. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman icon.